Find the missing value to
make the table represent
a linear equation.
So let's see this
table right over here.
So when x is equal
to 1, y is 3/2.
When x is 2, y is equal to 3.
So let's see what happened.
When x increased by
1, what did y do?
Well looks like y
increased by 3 and 1/2
is the same thing as 1 and 1/2.
So to go from 1 and 1/2 to
3, it increased by 1 and 1/2,
or you could say it
increased by 3/2.
You could say that 3 is the
same thing as 6/2, 6/2 minus 3/2
is another 3/2.
All right.
Now when we go
from 2 to 3, we're
increasing by 1 again in x.
And what are we doing in y?
So we're going from 3, which is
the same thing as 6/2 to 9/2.
So once again, we are
increasing by 3/2.
So in order for this
to be a linear equation
or a linear relationship,
every time we
increase by 1 in
the x direction,
we need to increase by 3/2.
If we increase by 2, we need
to increase by 2 times 3/2.
So what are we doing over
here on this fourth term
on the table?
Well we're increasing.
We're going from 3 to 8
so we are increasing by 5.
So if we're increasing
x by 5, then we
need to increase y by 5
times 3/2 or 15 over 2.
So that's the amount that
we have to increase y by.
If we started at 9/2 and we're
going to increase by 15/2,
so it's going to
be 9/2 plus 15/2,
this is how much
we increment by.
Remember, we increment
3/2 every time x moves 1.
This time, x moved 5.
So we're incrementing
by 15/2, or you
could say we're incrementing
by 3/2 five times.
But this is going
to be equal to 9
plus 15 is 24 over 2
which is equal to 12.
And so in the box, we could
write 12, and we are done.